سالتك عن اذا ما كان لديك الجديد بخصوص
هذه العمليه
[موسيقى]
ومرشح للارتفاع لان معظم الاصابات كانت
بين حرجه وخطره الاصابات في مجملها كانت
معي 10 مصابا منهم ثمانيه قتلى حتى الان
لكن هناك اثنان ايضا الجراحهم توصف
بالحرجه حسب الاسعاف الاسرائيلي ثانيا
هناك اغلاق تام لكافه الحواجز التي تقود
الى منطقه القدس بما فيها الحواجز
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي همم في منطقه
شعفاطمه
للقدس وكافه الحواجز التي من رام الله الى
القدس ومن بيت لحم الى القدس
سلطات الاحتلال دفعت لتعزيزتهم وقوات
ومفوض عام الشرطه بنفسه وصل الى مكان
الحادث في التفاصيل اللي بانها المهاجم
اطلق النيران عند مدخل احد الكونس داخل
الاستيطان في يعقوب فاصاب ثري 10 منهم
معظمهم كانت جراحهم بين خطيره توفي ثمانيه
منهم حتى الان لكن العدد مرشح لاكثر من
ذلك ثانيا في الاراضي الفلسطينيه هناك
حاله واضحه من انهم يعتبرون ذلك رده فعل
وفي الشوارع هناك حاله الى حد كبير من
الفرحه بان هناك رده فعل حصلت الان ونحن
نسمع همم سيارات كثيره تطلق صافراتها في
انحاء مختلفه هنا في منطقه همم رام الله
وقت الاحتلال كما قلت دفعت بقوات وتعزيزات
على نطاق واسع بينها وحدات من ما يعرف
بقوات النخبه في منطقه في يعقوب واغلقت
كافه الحواجز وتكون بعمليات تمشيط
للاشتباع بان هناك اكثر من مهاجم او ان
هناك كان مساعد لان عمليه اطلاق النار
يبدو انها من السلاح اوتوماتيكي وان
المطلق كان محترفا وقادر على تنفيذ ذلك
يشير الى ان حي يع هو حي استيطاني بني بعد
الحرب بعد عام 67 وهو مجاور لمنطقتي ضاحيه
بيت حنينا والرام وضاحيه البريد شمالي
الواقعتين شمالي القدس ولكنهما ضمن حدود
البلديه القدس بما فيها هذا الحي
الاستيطاني وهناك المنطقه هذه خاضعه
بالكامل للسيطره الاسرائيليه على كافه
المستويات وعندما يتمكن مهاجم فلسطيني من
دخول مثل هذا الحي لاسطاني وتنفيذ هذه
العمليه رغم كل الاجراءات الامنيه الزاجره
التي اتخذتها سلطات الاحتلال واضح
بانف الذي مارسه الاحتلال وتحديدا منذ
بدايه هذا العام والتصريحات التي اطلقها
قادته وزراعه خاصه الذي معروفين بعنصريتهم
تجاه الفلسطينيين وتعنيتهم لكل من يقتل
الفلسطيني هذا العنف يبدو انه لا يجر الا
العنف خاصه في ظل الغياب التام بما يعرف
بقضيه في الافق السياسي ثانيا لابد من
الاشاره بان مساله التنسيق الامني التي
كانت تتردد واعلنت السلطه الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه بانها لم تعد قائمه الى ايضا
همم قد تكون تلعب دور في كل هذه الامور
لكن الغضب في نفوس المواطنين كان كبيرا
جدا ووصل الى ذروه هائله مع شهدته جنين
امس